Speaker 1: Let's go next to Grant from Iowa City.
Grant, welcome to the show. What's going on?
Speaker 4: Hey, David. So I am about
a decade late in asking this question,
but I hadn't really paid attention to politics up
until the last couple of years ago. Okay. Anyway,
I was thinking back to Obama's
presidency and how there was such
drama surrounding his birth certificate
and all that, of course. And I was curious
how what's your perspective on requirement
for people to be natural born citizens in
order to be eligible for president?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I watched this a
little bit before. I mean, listen,
I. I am more in the direction of.
Naturalized citizens should be eligible,
primarily for the reason that without that,
you really are creating sort of two tiers of
citizens. You've got everybody is a citizen
on paper, but some are kind of like more citizens
than others, if that makes sense. Now, I do think
that it would be reasonable to say naturalized
citizens can be president, but you have to have
some additional you know, you've lived in the
U.S. for X amount of years. I'm completely open
to something like that. But I mean, listen,
not that I have any interest in running for
president. I was five when I moved to the United
States. I've been here more than 30 years.
Does it really make sense for me not to be allowed
to be president on that basis? I mean, I grew up
here. I've only voted here. I've only worked here.
I don't know. It just it doesn't really seem like
that's that that's problematic. But I am fine
with there being some requirement where, you know,
you if you've only been here, if you only been a
citizen for a year, maybe you can't be president.
But I'll have to tell you. I also understand the
argument of just letting the people decide. If the
voters say, hey, you know what? Even though this
person's a citizen, they've only been a citizen
a year. I don't think that that's who we need as
president. You could also make the case that you
don't even really need a rule. It should just
be up to the voters to decide. So yeah, for me,
I am significantly in the direction of allowing
naturalized citizens to run for president.
Speaker 4: Right. That makes sense to me too,
because I can completely understand. I think
the current requirement is you have to live in
the US for 14 years or be a citizen for 14 years
and you have to be 35 and like that makes sense to
me. The 35 years old is an arbitrary number, but
I guess it's understandable what you want people
to have a life experience that makes sense to me.
But yeah, the idea that you have to be a natural
born citizen is some people who literally can't
find an option for people to have like like for
yourself. And you do not plan to run. But like,
everyone has the least possibility of living in
the U.S. for 15 years. If you have the funds to
make it here and, you know, make the move. Yep.
Speaker 1: But you can't go back in history
and be born somewhere else, that's for sure.
Speaker 4: Right, exactly. Yeah. So. All right.
Speaker 1: Grant. Well, thank
you. I appreciate the question.
Speaker 4: I ask one extra little thing here.
Speaker 1: Oh, sure.
Speaker 4: Do you see there being a possibility of
that requirement being changed in the future? Is
that something that could be twisters up to? Sure.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I see a possibility of
it, although it doesn't seem like there's really
any big movement that's getting attention,
pushing for it right now.
So I wouldn't expect that
to happen any time soon.
Speaker 4: Okay. Again.
All right. Well, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks, Grant. There's Grant
from Iowa City with a very important question,
which everyone will say, my opinion doesn't matter
because I'm biased or something like that. Well,
then listen to someone else's opinion. Let's go to
Smitty from Los Angeles. Smitty, what's going on?
Speaker 5: Good morning, David. How are you? I'm
doing well. Sorry, not cut me off. I'm sorry.
I mean, it's habit. Well, I just wanted to say,
after, as I've continued to listen to you, I
have discovered that pretty much my politics
are exactly where yours is. Wow. I mean, I.
I definitely feel like, you know, there are
certain things that. You know that we need to
take a hold of from a public perspective with
education, with environment, with, you know,
certain industries that we should really have more
control over from the government perspective with
a lot of accountability. I think one of the issues
is also accountability. And this is my question.
Do you think it really is so much about left and
right, or do you think it really is more about
accountability? And do you think that it really
is a matter of how you structure your society, but
really having that accountability behind it? So
could you be a capitalist society as long as
there there's like a lot of accountability?
Or could you have a more socialist society with
a lot of accountability? I feel like we yourself
in justice playing this left right game. I
think it's more about that than it is about,
you know, better stuff.
Speaker 1: I don't know that. I would say
it's really about accountability. I mean, on many
issues, it is about where you are on the political
spectrum. You know, a woman's right to choose.
I don't think it's about accountability now.
What I will say is, like, for example, for many
right wingers who oppose abortion being legal,
they like to take this approach of,
well, it's about accountability in that
if you engage in the type of sexual
activity that leads to a pregnancy,
you have to be accountable by then carrying the
pregnancy to term. But I don't think that's the
type of accountability you're talking about.
Speaker 5: So I'm more boring. I'm sorry. It's
more on the, you know, the economical side I
definitely like or, you know, far left on people
should be allowed to do what they do.
Speaker 1: And yeah, no, I wasn't.
Speaker 5: Suggesting they were.
Speaker 1: Taking any particular position on
abortion. No, I don't I don't think I'm there. I
don't think I'm there on accountability. You know,
a lot of times there's this instinct sometimes
and I say this not to criticize you, but because
a lot of people do this, there's this instinct to
find sort of like the grand thing that explains
everything so often in society where people will
come and they'll say, you know, fundamentally,
all politics is about campaign finance. And
it's like, well, a lot of it is, but there's
also a lot of other stuff that's not about that.
And sometimes people will call in and they'll
say something like what you're saying, you know,
fundamentally it's not really about left, right.
It's about accountability. I think the the world
is so complicated that I wouldn't even waste time
looking for the one thing that it's really about.
Everything is about a lot of different things. And
I think that's the approach we should have.
Speaker 5: Okay. Well, that's good to know.
I do think accountability is definitely
a big part of it. All right. But, yes,
I think so. Thank you for your feedback.
Speaker 1: All right, Smitty from L.A.,
great to hear from you. Always appreciate it.
Let's go to I hope I pronounce this correctly.
Is this is it fit Phineas or pennies
from Kansas? How do you pronounce that?
Speaker 5: Hi, David. It's Phineas.
Phineas is based on Phineas Gage.
Speaker 1: Welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: So today, sir. I wanted to say,
first and foremost, I love the program and I
wanted to ask why certain democratic entities
would spend money specifically. I'm in
Kansas. I only would spend money to get
people to turn out for an abortion vote, but
then turn around and not invest any money in
like a governor race or a Senate race.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, because they see.
So you're saying why would they spend
money advertising that there is like
a ballot initiative on abortion or
a referendum and then the very same
people don't invest in like saying go vote for
this gubernatorial candidate who might have a
similar view on abortion, for example.
Speaker 5: Exactly. But talk to
the results of the recent Kansas election and
say, hey, you know, we got favorable results and
then turn around abandoned as come midterms.
Speaker 1: I have no idea. You'd have to ask
them. I think I'm just not really I'm not really
sure why, you know, why other people would or
would not spend money in a certain way. I'm not
really sure. I mean, there are some groups that
only work on ballot initiatives in referenda and
then don't work on candidate races. But I think
I just don't have all the information
to be able to give you an explanation.
Speaker 5: As far as you appreciate
your time on the ballot initiative.
Speaker 4: Once again, thank you very much, Steve.
Speaker 1: All right, Phineas. Sounds like
you've got a lot going on there
in Kansas, so I will let you go.